after searching hospitals and morgues
Muhammad ashrafil is hoping to find his
missing nephew at this makeshift camp in
balasor
22 year old Muhammad bowed the howrah
express one of the trains that collided
on Friday
today
I am running around in circles looking
for information the officials want me to
accept a body with a disfigured face as
my nephew how can they confirm this I
have been calling all the helpline
numbers there's no help now they want me
to go to another city to check the MOG I
don't have the money
[Music]
other families have had similar
experiences
there were six of them on the train we
live in the same place they were
supposed to go to Chennai we found four
of them in hospital but can't find the
other two
the government is under pressure to
provide answers Railways Minister
Ashwini vaishnav says a signaling error
cost the pile up
it is about the point machine and
electronic interlocking the change in
the electronic interlocking caused this
accident and whoever did it and whatever
other reasons will be known after the
investigation
the Army police and Railway workers have
joined teams from the udisha state
disaster management Agency on the ground
as the focus shifts from rescue mission
to clean up operation services on these
lines are expected to resume as early as
this week
India's Railway network is extensive
more than 12 million people commute by
train every day
to reduce travel times a new
japanese-funded bullet train is
scheduled to start running in 2026.
at a time when the government is
investing in high-speed trains an
accident like this one suggests its
priorities are not on track while
officials are trying to clear this mess
many families are still trying to find
their loved ones
in balasor eastern India